for one year now
Ukraine has stunned the world
many predicted that Keith would fall in
a matter of days but this did not
account
for the morale
and the physical courage
of Ukrainian people
you have resisted the Russian invasion
and pushed back against the aggressor
Against All Odds
we are with you we have been with you in
this existential fight from the
beginning we have massively stepped up
our economic humanitarian and Military
Support
because Ukraine has become the center of
our continent
the place where our values are upheld
where our freedom is defended
where the future of Europe is written
ukrainians are ready to die for the
European perspective we want them to
live with us the European dreams
Slava Ukrainian